i have this power but i don't know where  it came from  i had no idea i would ever get to do  something like this  i was over the moon when i found out who  else was gonna be in this film  it's like being invited to a party and  you know you're in good company  actors like to play in the marvel  studios sandbox  we made you one of us they understand  the excitement is there the drama is  there  the humor is in there they've been able  to find really great directors who are  focused on story it was so fun to cast  this movie  ben mendelsohn lashonna lynch jude blah  and that benning hello  total legend watching sam jackson is  just  you know a master class in itself prove  you're not a scroll  they are an incredible group of actors  who are really passionate about this  movie  and brought it to life in a great way  try to keep up